with reaction former Secretary of State
and Fox News contributor our friend Mike
Pompeo is Back Sir welcome back great to
have
you thank you SE great to be with you Mr
secretary we're worried about a
two-front war in the North uh hisbah and
and Lebanon uh and then of course Gaza
now we have Iran threatening and warning
Israel their time is up at that point in
time I know Israel it would be difficult
to two for War but if Iran involves
itself I would argue and correct me if
I'm wrong its very existence would be
hanging in the balance to me that would
be a threat to the entire region and
maybe the consequences even worse and I
don't even want to go there how bad
would that
be yeah it'd be deeply dangerous Sean
and and and I frankly think we're pretty
close to that today I do think we have
War at hand this barbarity that we saw
in the southern Israeli desert desert uh
we can't forget as you mentioned in your
opening monologue 30 Americans killed
and the president of the United States
travels to Israel and doesn't mention
the address to which this should be held
responsible right the Islamic Republic
of Iran I hope that we will continue to
give Israel the space and the resources
it needs to do the necessary for its own
people because it's necessary for
Americans as well there's still American
hostages being held there as well uh if
we just if we just get Hamas that will
be a good thing it will save lives it
will eliminate one threat to the Jewish
people in their Homeland but make no
mistake about it this came from Iran in
spite of President Biden and his team's
unwillingness to acknowledge that they
underwrote it they trained them they
prepared them there is no doubt they
knew about this and it will be their
decision about whether Hezbollah comes
in from the north and that this is not
inevitable America can deter a two-front
war for Israel but it's going to require
American leadership that I simply have
not seen and not appeasement and the
fact Sean that President Biden goes
there and says I'm going to give the
Palestinians another 100 $ million of US
taxpayer money is exactly the kind of
appeasement that brought us to the very
day that we're sitting in right here
today and by the way the PA reports are
that they're going to reward the
families of October 7th quote terrorists
with money uh which they have done
historically you're right about the100
million um here's the problem I've been
in in those tunnels that they dig with
Israeli money uh cement electricity
American money cement electricity in
other words money that we sent for
infrastructure schools hospitals they
use it to build tunnels to kill you know
the people in Israel so why would Joe
give them it's not going to go to the
Palestinian people that money is going
straight in hamas's Pocket am I
wrong no you're exactly right just as
we've been talking for years about the
fact that the Obama and Biden
administrations underwrote the Iranian
regime they have enforced sanctions Iran
now has some 50 60 billion do more than
they had when we left office in January
of 2021 they gave $6 billion to get five
hostages back and now the Iranians shot
hold more hostages than they did when we
paid ransom for the previous hostages
this policy is all just messed up it's
backwards instead of being a close Ally
in friend of Israel instead of
recognizing that the gulp Arab states
want to find a concordant they want to
find a way forward that's why we got the
Abraham Accords the B Administration
cozied up with the Iranians with the
Islamic Republic of Iran and created the
context against which the slaugh of 1300
Israelis took place let me ask you this
Mr secretary um I know because I spoke
to you when you were on the job as
Secretary of State and you were always
in some country but you had a great
relationship with with countries we
under the Trump Administration under
your leadership you forg relationships
with America with Israel with the
Egyptians the jordanians the Saudis the
Emirates all to fight back against
Iranian heemy in the region um that is
now gone how do you interpret that the
jordanians Egyptians even a boss
wouldn't meet with Joe Biden how do you
interpret
that Sean it's stunning I try to imagine
them checking out of a meeting with
President Trump like that I I we'd all
been working on the Tweet really quickly
uh because we would we I mean they're
laugh because it's it's laughable it
wouldn't
happen that that's right it's why it was
a bit of a joke and this is serious
stuff it it have happened they wouldn't
have walked away because they would have
known that they wanted to see the
president of United States and his
secretary state and they wanted to be
part of the the the conditions that
would have saved their lives too this is
not just the Iranian regime is not just
a threat to the people of Israel and the
United States they're launching missiles
from Yemen into Saudi Arabia they've
killed people in Europe This is a
challenge that confronts all people who
care about human dignity and decency and
so you know when President Biden says
you know we're just G to we're going to
allow them to have a missile program
that were going to let them build out
their nuclear program these are the
signals that tell the Ayatollah and RI
the leader of the leaders of Iran and
the irgc it tells them green light do
precisely what it was they did on
October 7th and the world has changed we
now need to make sure we give Israel
every space to do exactly what they need
to do and should America tell them to
stop I hope that they will choose not to
listen to do that which is necessary
they need to protect their borders in
very much the same way that we have the
responsibility to protect American
sovereign as well all right secretary
pompe always great to have you sir hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else